[Music]
Issa Rae is definitely ready to team up
with Rihanna the insecure star hosted
rereads diamond ball in New York City
Thursday night furthering rumors of a
possible movie collab you have a pen and
a paper to start keep writing I'm ready
to keep writing I'm a lone survivor I'm
ready I'm ready to work and I'm about to
take my little writing vacation after
this week oh really
so you gonna disappear for you gonna do
is it like I do live for your Instagram
I feel like I'm on the road with you and
on this journey with you really I do it
looks like from the outside in you are
completely living your best life
awkward black girl always coming back
okay you know i legit screamed on sunday
legette scream we got people i'm sure
that the seeker was gonna be out we were
like very worried about the fact that I
you know people were gonna know and then
people were surprised and it's the best
feeling ever but then you tried to say
you and J tried to say I never say every
time I get interview people
but I never said myself you never heard
it on my lips Lawrence isn't coming back
this season and I can any elevate you
look at we talk yeah it was like a
blessing people just the news around
with it and we loved it okay you gotta
go but quickly that awkward meeting
between exes yeah has that happened in
real life and how did you handle that
awkward meeting between exes it always
happens in real life
I'm always looking busted and you know I
handle it by just you know I feel like
I'm nan Xiang Yu and I'm in Thailand why
what today but you've gotta act on
things
[Music]